[Musique]
le roi d'Angleterre est de passage dans
les Yvelines de visites en France du 20
au 22 septembre Charles III rejoindra
Emmanuel Macron au château de Versailles
pour un dîner d’état une forme de clin
d'oeil à la reine Elizabeth II qui avait
déjeuné au même endroit en 1957 150
convives sont attendus dans la galerie
des Glaces le Téléthon c'est le 8 et 9
décembre prochain mais dans les Yvelines
la mobilisation a commencé depuis le 16
septembre Les Clayes-sous-Bois sera la
commune référence du mouvement elle
succède à manileamo pour représenter le
département activités sportives et
conférence sur les enjeux du mouvement
étaient au programme avec 12000 euros
collectés en 2022 la ville et les
bénévoles de l'association de la lutte
contre les maladies génétiques sont
prêts à relever le défi ce dimanche 17
septembre se tenait le workin update une
journée mondiale du nettoyage pour
prendre conscience de l'impact des
déchets sauvages sur notre environnement
sa poubelle pince et gants étaient les
outils indispensables pour dénicher les
détritus parfois bien caché dans les
buissons
une quinzaine d'habitants ont pris part
au rassemblement dans le quartier de la
mairie de Voisins-le-Bretonneux
mais oui il y a beaucoup de choses avant
on faisait ça aussi dans notre transmis
et puis j'adore l'écologie la nature et
du coup je les ai tous forcés et on aime
surtout bien nettoyer la vie pour que la
planète soit en bonne santé
en parallèle des journées du patrimoine
en 50 ans en Yvelines on fêté le vélo
samedi dernier visite du Vélodrome
national initiation au BMX et à la piste
de nombreuses activités étaient
proposées même préparé son propre jus de
pomme était possible à 10 mois des
épreuves de cyclisme de Paris 2024 c'est
aussi un moyen de mobiliser les
habitants salariés visiteurs de
Saint-Quentin autour d'un sport
fédérateur en sachant que que
Saint-Quentin accueille plusieurs
épreuves olympiques liées au vélo